you've probably been told to stay
indoors limit contact and go outside
only for essential activities all
because of this curve flatten the curve
the curve the curve this curve
flattening the curve
it shows the hypothetical number of
cases in a pandemic over time without an
intervention and with an intervention
the dotted line represents the capacity
of hospitals and healthcare systems if
social distancing goes well this curve
will be flattened allowing hospitals to
take in and discharge patients without
being overwhelmed the result more people
will get access to the health care and
attention they need and hopefully fewer
people will die but the x-axis
represents time since the first case if
you lower the peak the pandemic might
last longer because the number of new
cases will be spread out over a longer
period of time but the question on a lot
of people's minds is exactly how long
will that be right now the world is
trying to both flatten and shorten the
curve fewer cases and a shorter outbreak
but to do that we might need to live
like this for a while to understand why
we are social distancing or what the
World Health Organization now calls
physical distancing we need to explain
how easily the corona virus spreads in
order to best understand how contagious
and infectious diseases experts look to
a critical metric called the Arnott
value so that's basically the average
number of people that one sick person
can go on to infect in a group that has
no immunity to a virus the are not of
the corona virus is thought to be
between two and two and a half that
means that each person with the virus
could infect about 2.2 other people and
we also believe that it is possible for
people to be spreading this disease even
before they're feeling sick so we call
that pre-symptomatic transmission so all
that taken together means that this
thing spreads quite quickly and
sometimes silently for comparison the
are not of the flu is about 1.3 1.3
sounds close to 2.2 but the difference
can be huge someone with the flu might
pass it on to dozens of people but
someone with the corona virus might
indirectly pass it on to
thousands are not isn't a fixed number
but it does indicate how quickly the
virus is spreading a lower are not means
an outbreak is slowing or stopping while
a higher one means it's swelling as the
US test more people the number of cases
will continue to increase allowing us to
see the spread of the virus as it stands
if we slow the transmission of the virus
we lower the are not and eventually will
get from this part of the curve to that
and with no vaccine our best solution is
social distancing anything you do that
brings you in contact with other people
is a possible point of transmission this
is why we're seeing so many events get
canceled or postponed the earlier you
enact these measures the more rapidly
you can reduce the transmission rate the
faster we get to the point of reducing
the transmission rate the faster we
could get to the end of the outbreak
essentially not just flattening the
curve but making it smaller but if you
wait until everyone around you is sick
it'll be too late there's still time to
contain this outbreak and that's why we
all are inside because it's still
possible to get this under control
testing will catch people who are sick
enough to go to the hospital but not
necessarily people who have mild or no
symptoms and those people could still
spread to the average to point to other
people to prevent this many states have
issued stay at home orders which allow
only essential businesses like grocery
stores and pharmacies to remain open but
how long will things be like this it's
hard to project what's going to happen
because the course of these outbreaks is
really going to depend on the measures
that we take as communities the truth is
no one actually knows how long we will
have to social distance you can't see
the peak of the curve when you're still
in the upward slope and each state is
handling things differently
Illinois's stay at home order is
expected to be in effect until April 7th
but in some states like California and
New York
there is no projected end date
a March 15 the CDC of ice against
gatherings of 50 or more people for
eight weeks and many universities have
told students that the rest of the
semester will be online but some
officials stress that things can be like
this for even longer you're not going to
turn on the news tomorrow morning and
they're going to say surprise surprise
this is all now resolved in two weeks
that is not going to happen ultimately
experts say that those social distancing
measures will sort of be necessary until
we have a vaccine and that's 12 to 18
five of us so that's sort of at the very
far end of things but that doesn't
necessarily mean we're all in our homes
for 18 months it means maybe we're
avoiding public gatherings for that
amount of time we're limiting the amount
of travel internationally but it's not
necessarily as restrictive as what we're
seeing now there's no magic number that
suddenly shows you're on the downturn of
an epidemic growth curve however by
tracking the number of new cases per day
and by seeing that number decreased
consistently over time I think that's
really a good litmus test for knowing
that perhaps the peak is behind you
we've seen other countries like China
and South Korea dramatically lower the
number of daily reported cases after
implementing broad testing and social
distancing measures but it's important
to note that some experts think there
could be another round of social
distancing we start letting people go
back to work go back to school and then
once that happens the virus would have
an opportunity to spread again and there
would be a second wave of infection if
we end social distancing too soon new
cases could pop up and we could end up
in another curve again if the number of
reported cases spikes again we might
have to enact the same policies we have
in place now which might be stressful to
hear but is important to stay calm and
follow the advice of health care
professionals when you take measures to
prevent yourself from getting infected
or spreading the disease to others you
may be indirectly saving other people's
lives right now the u.s. still on the
upward slope of the curve but we won't
be forever
and all of our actions can directly
affect the slope of that curve